selena gomez is offering an apology
after she was accused of poking fun at
haley bieber's expense oh my goodness
here's what we know
i'm gonna show you guys how i do
my skin prep haley frequently posts
beauty tutorials like these to social
media and the model is married to pop
superstar justin bieber who dated selena
on and off for years the two officially
went their separate ways in 2018 the
same year justin and haley kicked off
their romance fast forward to this week
i really love it
haley shares a series of get ready with
me style videos to tick-tock not too
long after selena posts her own skincare
routine breakdown
[Applause]
[Music]
now for some fans the proximity of their
videos was telling with many concluding
she had to be mocking her ex's bow
selena's alleged eye role in the post is
also being cited as evidence she was
indeed throwing shade
[Music]
admitting she's a little confused by the
situation selena later decides to speak
out with the reaction coming from a fan
account's viral screenshot before the
video's comments were disabled the
screenshot allegedly shows a comment
selena left on tick tock the message
reads this is why i believe in taking
care of your mental health guys no idea
what i did but i am really sorry zero
bad intention deleting soon the
controversy comes shortly after haley's
emotional plate leave me alone at this
point i'm minding my business following
rumors surrounding her and justin's
marriage last month she took to
tick-tock to air her frustrations
i don't do anything i don't say anything
leave me alone please enough time has
gone by where it's valid to leave me
alone i beg of you truly
that's my only request leave me alone
be miserable somewhere else please
meanwhile selena is getting candid with
her own struggles with social media i'm
constantly somebody that likes to grow
and feel like all right what could i be
better at what could i do better at
where
where could my confidence be stronger
back in january the former disney star
opened up to in style magazine where she
admitted instagram was dangerous for her
adding that at one point it became her
whole world and she never felt pretty
enough leading to a hiatus from the
platform quote i created a system where
i still don't have my passwords and the
unnecessary hate and comparisons went
away once i put my phone down i'll have
moments where that weird feeling will
come back but now i have a much better
relationship with myself
you know my personal life and my family
and my friends i'm just i'm in a really
happy place it's been good
[Music]